[Music]
hi everybody i'm a tad hunt and today
we're gonna be talking about optimizing
file storage for your use case if you
are hoping to learn about something else
like maybe block or persistent disk
you're in the wrong place
so I'm the product manager for file in
Google Cloud I I'm actually a file
system geek before Google I built a file
system company and I've been working on
file for about 10 years now in my spare
time I'm a rock climber right no one
else do kind of any extreme sports nice
nice I can't see much most people all
right
this is up in Yosemite pretty cool our
agenda today is we're going to cover
kind of an intro about the file storage
options in Google cloud and then we're
gonna deep dive into three managed
services that we provide Google's cloud
file store elasto files cloud file
service and NetApp's cloud volumes so
just to be clear what are we covering
today what we're covering object block
that's somebody else hopefully you've
gone to some of those interesting
sessions as well
we're gonna talk about file so where do
I store my data and this taxonomy of
storage systems we generally break it
down into some structured which is
databases and unstructured storage
systems like file block and object this
is the file the file bit the key
takeaway here is that GCP has lots of
storage options whether you have
structured or unstructured storage needs
we basically have all the things which
is good for you and good for us all
right so let's dive into some file use
cases really quickly here this is not
the complete set of use cases there's a
lots of ways to slice and dice file
we're going to talk about them in these
categories general purpose and as some
high-performance computing stuff some
hybrid cloud stuff backup and archive
and as gateway scalable caching in CSP
storage which we have a new name for for
this cloud services platform anyone
remember the name from the keynote
anthos alright good good cool so we all
know that file workloads are incredibly
varied and our first party offering
which is file store here on the top
left it won't always be the best choice
and for that reason we're committed to
supporting a strong partner ecosystem we
have some of our partners up here to
present and talk about their offerings
meeting customers we're like you where
you are where you're where you are often
means providing the same tools that
you're already using on Prem or that
having the advanced feature set that you
might need our partners complement file
store with things like scale out
performance rich and deep feature sets
with you know well-established histories
support for hybrid cloud and container
storage the ability to stitch together
lots of distributed storage sites you
know and many more this is possible
because we believe that a strong third
party partner ecosystem actually
recruits the best expertise across the
industry to solve your problems that any
one of us isn't going to be able to
solve all of together and by ourselves
right so together the end result is you
get the best solution for your problem
we're not obviously going to cover all
of these use cases today or the myriad
other use cases that there might be but
we are going to cover a couple of really
cool exciting examples I think so if you
are crazy excited about file and you
just can't get enough we've got a lot
more storage sessions about file I'm not
going to read these feel free to you
know take a picture or you know look
them up later we're going to cover some
of the workloads in the sweet spots for
file store net up and last a file but
these are a small fraction of file
workloads Google is actually ready to
solve a lot more of your file storage
needs I think you know in my opinion
we're the best cloud for that these days
we've also got talks specifically
covering rendering hybrid cloud and HPC
and so feel free to jump in and those
you'll have to pick between rendering or
or hybrid so if you need to do some
hybrid rendering you got to split your
time between those all right let's talk
about file store and then we're going to
dive into elasto file and net up
following so today I'm actually super
excited to announce cloud file stores
general availability I launched actually
today so there'll be a big blog post
going out tomorrow with this so the two
main differences between beta and GA are
is we have increased the performance
which I'll show you in just a
and we've added an SLA so now we have a
three nines SLA it's live in production
now if you check out their website all
the uh Doc's are updated you can see all
the you can see all of the info so
anyone in the audience I can barely see
you about anyone the audience using file
store today one two three there's a
bunch of you alright so NFS and shared
file systems are like the arteries of
many enterprise workloads and in a way
Enterprise is doubling down in a big way
Enterprise is doubling down on GCP and
hybrid cloud in part because now it's
it's mature and it can actually run a
lot of these enterprise workloads you
know the long tail of enterprise
workloads that you might have with file
store now generally available and the
rich set of partners we'll talk about a
bit later you can make the choice to
lift and shift your apps rather than
rewriting to object or database and so
this actually helps ease your migration
to cloud feedback during beta has been
generally overwhelmingly positive and we
have actually got PayPal up here to talk
about some some of the observations
they've made during our beta program so
we're going to talk about detailed use
cases like at a high level let's say
that file store and the general purpose
workload it's unblocked small to
mid-size of kale compute clusters and
enterprise applications that need access
to shared file systems let's see
alright so Jason put your hand up
everybody give mad props to Jason he's
an engineer on the file store team so
you know him in the whole rest of the
team have made the made this possible I
just get to talk about it alright and if
you have any technical questions
afterwards catch him before he runs away
cool so here's a couple of you know
maybe a top-five file store use cases
that we're seeing from our beta program
you know what's file store good at that
well obviously a lot more than this but
some of the key workloads we've already
tuned file store for our rendering
application migrations this sort of the
long tail of enterprise apps web content
management media processing in in Devon
test environments I'm not going to dive
into any of these right now the really
exciting thing is PayPal is going to
dive do a really deep dive into dev test
I think you'll be really excited
and it's pretty interesting you know
what's one key thing that all of these
and probably all of your file workloads
rely on well probably performance so
we're actually pleased to announce with
GA we've increased performance
sequential read on premium instances to
1.2 gigabytes per second and we've
increased random read I ops from 30,000
to 60,000 so these are actually pretty
significant performance increases and if
you've been playing with the beta these
actually rolled out midway through our
beta and so you actually get to take
advantage of this with you no no no no
change in price or anything so this is
actually a super exciting so we didn't
just make file store fast we actually
made it really easy to reason about the
performance you get if your price
sensitive pick standard and in which
case your performance varies a little
bit based on capacity if you are
performance sensitive pick premium your
performance doesn't vary no matter what
scale and you're not paying per eye up
you're just paying dollars per gig per
month and it's a fixed flat fee and in
fact you pre provision your capacity and
so you know right up front I'm gonna
spend this many dollars on storage and
so it's actually pretty cool you know in
terms of your pricing and predict pretty
predicting your pricing it's it's great
you know let's talk quickly about
features there's this is kind of an eye
chart so I'm not gonna spend a lot of
time here but at a high level you can
configure shares up to about 64
terabytes premium and standard have
different minimum sizes so that you we
can guarantee the performance when the
really exciting thing is is is because
you have to pre provision your size not
only do you know how much you're gonna
pay at the end of the month but you can
actually grow it online and we have
stackdriver metrics which in alerts
which can automatically fire and do
things like webhooks automatically grow
the size should you want to do that so
you can you can get you know a page if
you're gonna exceed the capacity you
think you should pay for as well we are
at about 500 active clients out of about
5,000 connected that's you know kind of
a small render farm or a you know small
batch workload or even maybe a minimum
mid-sized batch workload we're a zonal
service with high availability
you know with three nines SLA and
typical recovery time you know when we
need to reboot for software upgrade or
you know we detect an issue is typically
under under 120 seconds which is within
the henna fest time out from a
networking perspective everything is
super secure we're we're RFC 1918
private IP addresses and you can access
it you know crosses own in cross region
but not from the public Internet
anyone ever put an NFS server on the
public Internet I've done it don't do it
it's not a good idea so you can't even
you can't even do that if you wanted to
in Google Cloud which is great and like
all Google products were super secure we
think security is really important and
so we have encryption at rest and in
transit according to the rest of the
platform so there's some details and
some white papers that we've released
there you know integrations you know we
were integrated with a lot of a lot of
the main things that you're going to use
in mgcp like particularly compute engine
GCE and kubernetes engine gke on compute
engine I especially want to call out
we're integrated not only with regular
VMs but also preemptable VMs so this is
really great for your you know your
batch of compute workloads and
kubernetes engine in gke we're
integrated with the CSI driver and so
you can actually dynamically provision
file store instances speaking about
dynamic queue provisioning there's two
ways to do that as well you can go to
the I mean you can go to the console and
you know which is the GUI you can do it
via API or you can use our command line
but you can also use it through
deployment manager which is you know our
native offering and also terraform I
think the terraform team tells me
something like 10 or 15 percent of file
store configurations are done through
Tara format in fact which is pretty cool
so we have a we worked with the the
Hashi Corp to to put our integration in
their cool now we're storage product and
so backups you know more more
traditional right rather than object
storage kind of which is a you know
cloud native so backups are a thing
we're integrated with both actifi oh and
CommVault which are two of the leading
third party you know backup vendors you
anyone using any of these you Activia or
CommVault already
these are these are pretty common a
couple of people all right and just to
kind of wrap up this section file store
is available in almost all GCP regions
there's probably three or four regions
which were not deployed in yet due to
some capacity constraints for us but
that'll happen later this year and it's
in GA it's GA in all of these regions
right now all right
so that's the quick run-through for file
store we'll have time for questions at
the end if you have to kind of any
specific questions or you can hit me up
or any other presenters right now you
know I'm paid to tell you file stores
great so you probably shouldn't believe
me entirely I think you should but maybe
not entirely so let's fix that please
join me in welcoming Dinesh madavan
I probably said his name wrong I only
have American phonemes the senior
software engineer at PayPal he's going
to tell us all about the PayPal
development teams journey from
completely on-premise into completely
cloud-based
development and test thank you Dad hi
everyone I'm Danish Marlon I've been a
senior software engineer at PayPal doing
mostly developer experience like SEM
Jenkins and deploys so let's get into
what paperless so this is a PayPal
journey to cloud we began way back in
2014 with the decision to container is
everything and we tried a lot of stuff
while most much of admit was useful in
unmade developers life easier the
developer experience team increasingly
struggled with growing the scale and
complexity of managing Z systems this
led us to directly to decision to
migrate everything to cloud so that
Google could carry out the burden of
keeping the infrastructure healthy and
we could focus on the developer
experience desin and the infrastructure
to put this in some context in 2013 we
started the journey with one monolithic
Jenkins with hundreds of plugins and
more than 40,000 jobs on running on a
deal 980 and this got better after we
migrated to OpenStack and we used miso
this marathon and docker
from 2014 2016 and by 2018 we were
creating so many jobs that we were not
able to scale so we had to
it was a pain to sand up our own
infrastructure which it was a bottleneck
for all developers so we started
migrating to Google cloud in 20 20 18 we
started migrating all our dev and test
to cloud which has enabled us to scale
to more than 12 million jobs per year we
are truly scalable now and this was a
huge win for us and in 2019 we are
planning to migrate or mobile SDLC also
and use file store for more use cases at
PayPal so to understand why file store
is important to us I need to describe
our development architecture and scale
we'll start with that and then dive into
where file store helps us out we were
early adopters of file store we were
amongst the first very first customer
when it launched in beta back in July
2018 which means that we can also cover
our experience with file source
reliability and availability during that
time finally I wrap up by talking about
what we are going to do next and what we
are what kind of platform we are giving
to our developers so this is a rock
texture papers developer experience is
centralized around the continuous
integration and continuous deployment
pipeline built on top of Jenkins the
leading open source automation server me
sauce Aurora's zookeeper MongoDB and
nginx
when developer commits their code a
build is automatically kicked off a unit
tests are run and the docker image that
is built is deployed to a server and all
the functional tests are completed and
it's automatically approved to be pushed
to production and this basically happens
everything in Jenkins core Jenkins
master that is the core of our
development architecture so we make sure
each development team is not blocked by
any other team by providing one Jenkins
master for every every team that's there
we also use miso Stockard straight our
Jenkins master enslaves which enables us
to manage our fleet of GC VMs as a
single pool of resources that we can
scale up and down on demand all about
this we also provide a continuous
integration API which encapsulates our
CI CD functionality or Aurora framework
schedules the wrong running process and
our cron jobs file store here provides a
in storage for Jenkins masters we were
able to scale the number of files or in
instant instances with sub linearly with
respect to the number of Jenkins masters
which is not just a testament to the
file serve performance but also helps
with manageability because there are
less resources to keep track of so
before file store each Jenkins master
also can included the CI data this means
said the backup has to back up all the
CA data that was inside the Jenkins
master container you can recall that we
were well on our way to fight thousand
Jenkins master containers and as you can
imagine this was a huge scalability
issue for us and also it was not as
reliable as we want it to be and all the
data that was in the CI we are backing
up to GCS and learned that encryption
compression and network latency is not
your friend
so during this era of rapid growth we
were in neverending cycle of container
failures and also data loss and leading
to a poor and unproductive developer
experience so we stepped back and looked
for alternative solutions naturally we
thought that making the container
stateless is the way to go and file
store was launching beta the same at the
same time and it turned out that this
was exactly what we needed to refractor
the statefulness of out so during so the
let's talk about use case or with file
store so what what we did was we were
backing up everything in our containers
and it was the containers was going out
of memory so we completely removed the
process of backing up and restoring from
inside the container and we moved all
our data to the file store and we were
able to scale our containers to more
than five thousand and we were putting
it on file files for incident mounted on
multiple VMs and because we did remove
our architecture to the file store we
were able to completely get rid of the
container backups and after moving to
the new process we were able to start up
our containers from which was taking
many hours more sometimes three to four
hours to be less than a minute
which was a huge win for us so you can
really recall from my earlier comments
that we were being files for customer
since beta launched and we have seen the
service go from where we were and sure
we could run in production to a point
where we're pleased with his reliability
and availability when we migrated Phi so
last year we were our metrics fact
multiple outages which sometimes lasted
more than ten minutes and this cost our
workloads to freeze and the developments
is tall this means said all of PayPal
could not run any bills or any deploys
and everything was frozen we work
closely for the file store team on these
issues and all the last six months we
are not seen one issue where file store
existed SLA and this was not even
officially GA yet so which is a good
thing it's this significantly reduce our
support cost which is a fancy way of
putting that I'm not getting paged
anymore so the most important outcome of
this thing is our cos our developers are
no longer experiencing productivity lost
due to the CSCS CCD system being done so
moving forward we are looking at more
performance intensive workloads and to
run our bills also on the file stores
currently we are using a local SSD
exported we don't expect
network-attached storage to be quite as
fast as a local but we think that it's
fast enough and the performance
trade-off is worth this simplification
was to build the slave environment we
are just began looking into the
restructuring our Android and iOS mobile
building tests and we think that will
also get the similar level of
maintainability and scalability out of
file store thanks for listening everyone
that's what what's up at PayPal and I'll
call that back and hand it off thanks
Ashley cool that was great
you know it's not every day that a
development organization the size of
PayPal's make such a large sweeping
change you know in a migration like this
so it's pretty exciting to be you know I
have them part of the file store beta
and to help make file store you know the
strong product that it is now in terms
of its SLA and features if you have
questions about this or anything else as
we go along
and everyone else will be available for
Q&A at the end and he'll be around the
conference I think a little bit more as
well so if you run into him definitely
get the get the inside scoop you know
next up we're going to talk about alaska
files recently launched cloud file
service so i'd like to introduce Alan
Cohen and Devin Lehmann from Alaska file
in google respectively come on up
awesome thanks dad
so bridging off of Tad's rock climbing
photo show that I'm a snowboarder who's
sorry lucky enough to work at Google but
any snowboarding photos and oh so that's
a photo of me jumping out of a perfectly
good airplane and for my day job I'm an
engineering program manager on GCP who's
responsible for working with our
technology partners like a last file and
so I'm up here with my colleague along
Thank You Devin so this is a before
picture the after picture isn't this
pretty we'll be introducing to you the
Alaska file file service and thank you
so Alaska file offers a fully managed
file storage as a service inside Google
cloud were POSIX compliant which means
that you can move enterprise workloads
such as s IP directly to the cloud
without the need for refactoring we are
scalable and this is one of our key
differentiators and we'll show you this
shortly in the demo as well because
we're software-defined essentially you
can dynamically grow us and shrink us
upon need and your charge by the minute
when you use more you pay as much as you
use when you don't need it anymore you
can just shrink it down or close it up
all together we provide enterprise
feature sets such as a chase snapshots D
Tube compression so you really can
migrate and move to working the way you
worked on Prem even as you migrate into
the cloud and we are cloud native as a
software offering we appear in any
region in any zone and can even offer
the service across their zones anywhere
where Google provides infrastructure we
can provide our
file service we are fully integrated
into the Google environment including
both on Prem and the new or including
both cloud and the new on Prem offerings
and you can get our billing through
Google billing and access us through
Google UI you don't need to believe me
because I'll give it back to Devin we
will demonstrate it for you okay thanks
a lot so if you could switch over to my
laptop is if you kind of like what I'd
like type and use the hand week is
bridging up for the wand said how easy
it is to find enable and then create in
the last file cluster all from the
console so if you've ever used GCP
before you're gonna see it's the exact
same looking feel from deploying
anything like cloud storage I gave a
tile clearly says the last two file
there's syntax branding last two file
but it's all powered by last two files
back end
I hit manage it brings me into the
product page at which you're gonna see
cluster details so no need to run
scripts no need for authorization
authentication protocols I just hit
create and within the product page and
again standard syntax you'd expect so
file name I can call it test next region
deployment and this is super important
when I talk about this for a second so
lost files managed file service is
deployed holistically on TCP so similar
to file store or any region where we
have PD and compute and the
corresponding software for last file you
can deploy this cluster and easily and
also then mount your client from that
region so if I want to do something like
US central one and select the particular
zone I can do that or select region on
the last of all managed servers will do
it for you you have the ability to then
select the service class which expect
high performance general use or
something else and then you can see
underneath here estimated total this is
really great because you can see what
does the cost of co-creation is gonna be
this is an estimate but you know at the
end of the month what you'd be expecting
use subjected to that particular service
class and then you can select allocated
capacity all this is dynamic sliders
will change it's a really easy way to
sue this cost
gonna be from here you can do authorized
Network so this is where you set up your
V PC peering network either local or
shared I've got a couple before it I can
select but if you haven't done it from
the UI prompts will show up you can't be
you throw in your terminal it's up and
running in no time
and you don't have to do anything
outside of the console there's a couple
Advanced Options we can show you as well
so if you're restricting client access
or opening up client access you have the
ability to create read write rules or
delete read write rules that exist and
then able straight snapshot straight
from the UI so all one page all easly
when I cancel just to give you a quick
view of looks like main page and then
you have the ability kind of someone we
were talking about before but logging
into stack drive to get advanced
analytics in metrics so if you want to
have logs data I can select any one of
my existing instances and it'll redirect
me within the console to see what's
going on but if I want to log out to
stock driver instead of learning and
reporting we have a functionality to I'm
super quick demo come talk to us
afterwards and we keep it more robust
one but I want to pass the mic back over
to a LAN so that you can show you what
this looks like just scale out a lot to
file cloud files per Thank You Devin so
we did want to show you a bit of this in
action so if we can switch back to the
other computer what we're going to show
you is essentially a demo of an HPC
workload will do this in theory nina's
on the top right you see the performance
from coming from the last file system on
the bottom right you see the Google
console showing you the VMs that were
spinning up and on the left you actually
see orchestration we are fully
accessible via API and in this case
we're using slurm to automate the bring
up of 1,000 VMs these are preemptable
VMs which is another great reason to use
a file service you can save a lot by
using the preemptable VMs if someone
falls no issue you have persistent
storage as a service you spin up another
VM through the orchestration and that VM
will access the data we have just spun
up a thousand of these VMs for
orchestration and what
want to follow is a bit of the
throughput that we are achieving and the
connections we're actually using to NFS
mounts for each one of those VM so you
can see the count of connections a
rising up right now at 1,300 growing up
to those 2,000 connections for those
2000 VMs and the fruitwood we're running
now is upward of two point four
gigabytes per second this is not the
limit but in terms of cost even though
we're using preemptable VMs we didn't
want to go much beyond 1000 you see now
a tail there of workloads and that's
actually the orchestration system
bringing up additional VMs which were
preempted earlier so if you needed to
complete the project no problem
through the automations even though
Google infrastructure took one of yours
VMs they're simply spun back up and used
as Devon said come ask us say afterwards
any questions and we also have a booth
here which we can show you for the demos
thank you back to you Ted cool Thank You
Allan and Devin that was a really
exciting demo anyone ever see in another
and anyone's cloud kind of scaling up to
that many gigabytes per second of
throughput that quickly that was pretty
awesome
so next up we're gonna have Niraj from
NetApp give us a talk about cloud
volumes their new cloud volume service
from net up so please join me in
welcoming
Niraj come on this side
thank you Dad good afternoon everyone
Anna Raj Varma technical marketing
engineer here at NetApp I recently
joined our Cloud Data Services business
unit I focus solely on cloud volume
service for GCP and I'm very interested
in listening to what you have to say on
what you see today the demo as well as
the product I work very closely with the
product manager I'd love to bring back
some feedback or questions that you may
have clicker with that just to frame the
conversation we'll spend just maybe five
minutes on this one slide and then I'll
go into a basic demo off the UI and then
after that I'll show you another demo of
an application use case where we go
through some of the features of the
product so we'll first define the
service what is NetApp cloud volume
service the simplest way to think of it
is that it is an NFS or an SMB endpoint
in Google cloud and as far as the
features and some of the benefits that
you get for your applications your
system design and your users first we
have the standard file interfaces that
you can deploy you have your NFS for
your UNIX applications and SMB for your
Windows applications and and one thing
to point out here is that
Nerra has been a pioneer and a leader in
the shared file space for over two
decades
now and we bring that experience and
more importantly the stability of our
technology to Google cloud next sorry I
should have mentioned going from top
left down second we have the fully
managed service tenets where we don't
want you to be in the in the business
sustaining of this infrastructure
underlying infrastructure even one-time
so right when you deploy your
application from the get-go you have
this available for you to quickly spin
up and mount on your application without
having to then even worry about the
lifecycle of that application when it
comes to patching or scaling the storage
that's using multiple performance levels
the service comes in three flavors
standard premium and extreme each of
these three flavors have a performance
metric associated with it and I'll show
you more of that in the demo but think
of it as the two dimensional service
capacity and performance and you get it
in three different flavors standard
premium and extreme the fourth fourth
thing in the bottom left rich data
management
this for us is a key differentiator we
not only allow you to quickly spin up
end points for your application but we
also think about the lifecycle of that
end point when it comes to protecting
your data as well as creating rapid
copies for your application lifecycle
going from dev to test staging on your
pathway to production moving to the top
right native service experience no
experience was was a key design goal for
us when we started working on this
service and you'll see in the demo next
in the basic UI demo that what I mean by
that you don't have to go outside the
Google ecosystem in your in your
application storage journey when it
comes to support again as I mentioned
experience was not just from looking
field standpoint we also wanted to think
about your your journey as a engineer as
an architect as a DevOps engineer when
it comes to support we know that things
are going to break and you're going to
need some help so what we've done here
is that we allow you to talk to your
same Google Google ecosystem for your
level one support and that I will work
with you on the back end for l-2 and l-3
escalation cases as needed and billing
is also integrated we don't want you to
manage a second contract or a second
piece of paper you get the same bill
that you get from Google with the line
item for NetApp based on the performance
service level that you choose and being
a true cloud service we also allow you
to pay for what you use on an hourly
basis as you go with that I'll move over
to my laptop for a quick UI demo all
right so as you can see here I'm
currently logging into the Google
console and I'm currently in the API
library page and I can simply type that
up here and it brings up the net app
cloud volume service API since I already
have it enabled I can then click on
manage and this brings me into the
dashboard for cloud volume service
listed here are some volumes that I
created in the USC's for region way too
many of them you can see quickly the
name all the key detail that you need
just to get a quick snapshot of your
state the region life cycle if it's
available in mounted service level the
mount pad capacity and the protocol that
you're using on the left you see this
tab right here the volume and then you
also have a snapshot tab which I'll talk
about in a second here and then you have
the ad connections tab for your SMB
volume creation so I'm going to go and
click create and here you can see that I
have two options NFS and SMB I'm gonna
give it a name here real quick key pay
attention to how much time it takes for
me to go from here till the volume
creation and I'll tell you why so once I
give it a name I have the path
automatically chosen for me you can
change it but make sure if it's if you
change it it's unique across the entire
project
speaking of service level here they are
three service levels with the
performance that you can expect from
each of them if you stop by the net I
boot I can I can demonstrate the
performance aspect of ds3 alive over
there but for now I'm gonna choose your
C's for region this tab right here a
snapshot now this allows you to create a
non-dimensional this allows you to
create a volume just like we are from an
from a snapshot that you previously
created of another volume from that tab
on the top left we're not doing that in
this case so I'll skip that we're
creating a new volume so I'll give it a
minimum size of one terabyte and then
you have your standard NFS export policy
permissioning I'm gonna add a rule to
open all I'm very generous with my
security so I open it to all clients and
then I can choose read and write and
with that done last thing I'll mention
here before I click Save is I can now
also take snapshots on an automated
fashion where I can then set my schedule
hourly daily weekly minutes and also my
retention I'm not doing that in this
case I'll click Save as I mentioned pay
attention I click Save and it takes me a
couple seconds so we actually you don't
from me we have a contest going on in a
booth if you do this and if you do it
the fastest and you'll get it both
wireless headset you didn't hear this
from me again right now I think that the
clock is about 25 seconds and I think
you can easily beat that this is the
basic demo I'm not going to mount this
volume to an instance but I'll show you
if you wanted to do that you can quickly
click on this icon right here and you
can check out your mount instruction
simply copy and paste that in your Linux
as an SSH session and you'll be able to
do that now with this basic demo coming
to the conclusion I'm going to switch
over to an application demo I've kept
this application the most simple what I
have here is a Google cloud instance
computer instance which I call
confluence next demo and in the next
next screen I have a cloud volume from
that app also called confluence next
data and what I'm doing is I'm
installing confluence this is an
application example of an enterprise
content management system where you're
sharing and collaborating files so I
install that app on that Google instance
and then I switch the directory for data
to that cloud volume I just created the
app is installed now what I'll do is
I'll fire it up create a new workspace
call it DevOps and then I'll add some
data some couple of web pages and some
pictures just to show you a production
state you have some data running on your
application once this is done
what I'm gonna try to depict here is
that now you have data and application
running on cloud volumes in Google and
you know let's say in production right
and maybe you have a business need you
want to make some changes to your steady
state and you want to maybe do an
upgrade or add some or maybe move this
copy of your entire application to
another environment let's say PT or
something right so what you can then do
is you can take an on-demand snapshot
that I showed you in the UI demo earlier
you do that by clicking on that top left
snapshot icon or you can edit the the
volume once you take the snapshot the
nice thing is that then you can clone
this snapshot and create a new volume
from that snapshot this volume that's
being created is now going to be also
resized in the process so you can change
it from one terabytes to two terabytes
now you mount it back to your confluence
instance and you'll notice that I'll
change the directory for the data and
I'll still have all of my web pages in
the data that I created in the previous
step we've got a bit of head of myself
there it is so the new data volume was
mounted and I have my data at the same
time I'm also migrating my application
from version 6.1 to the latest version
of this app and I can do that now
because I'm confident that if anything
goes wrong I can go back to that point
in time copy of the snapshot that I that
I created that's the demo thank you can
I switch back to the PowerPoint next
slide I should do that
okay so just do on a closing note the
service is currently in paid alpha so
you have to be white listed in order to
access the service but that's changing
next month when we go to beta release a
couple of new features that are coming
out with beta will be exposing our API
so now you can take that API and
programmatically access cloud volumes
with other Google technologies and and
provision that from from from your
Google Cloud command line tools and the
other cool feature that's coming out in
beta is that will be automating the
entire process of white listing and
onboarding so you can now self-service
fashion access the service is open to
all basically next month from a regional
standpoint currently we are available in
central one and us sees four regions but
we'll be adding us west one which is LA
and EU West two which is I believe it's
Frankfurt in the summer time frame and
then following that would be London and
Sydney I think I'll stop with that tad
so thank you all for listening and back
to you
great awesome demo thanks Josh cool so
that was a great demo of some key
enterprise collaboration workflow on GCP
and of course the UI for the cloud
volume service so this is at the wrap up
section so I'm just going to summarize
what we covered you know we covered
cloud file stores ability to do some
general-purpose and ads and kind of
drill down into the dev test area we
looked at Alaska Files GK and
preemptable VM story for a large scale
and we looked at net apps enterprise
content management and then so I think
the really cool thing here is you see
three different managed services all
built on GCP and while we talked about
at our keynote this morning the open
source services platform right and and
bringing open sourcing we're actually
doing the same thing and we've we've
really prototype that with with with
these industry partners as well so of
course there's a lot more workloads that
all of our partners in file store can do
right so please check out you know these
folks websites some of the other
sessions we talked about and everything
else out there the key takeaway here is
if you walk away with only one thing is
Google Cloud
is actually you know very ready for your
enterprise workloads bring them on
[Music]